grab some delicious peach pie and stay
off my property
off my property
because we finally have a jack reacher
that's over five foot seven amazon's
reacher is a throwback to when men
didn't cry and action dialogue was just
that perfect level of cheesy i will ruin
your life with one phone call i'll end
your life with one phone
so reach for that like and subscribe
button yes the puns get worse as we take
a deep dive into the ending of reacher i
don't give a [ __ ] meet jack reacher a
six foot five ex-army major who loves
the blues almost as much as he loves
kicking ass
he's found himself in margrave georgia
to visit the site where one of his
favorite jazz musicians blind blake died
in fact if you listen carefully this
song that plays in the very last scene
of the season is blind blake's police
dog blues which has the line all my life
i've been a traveling man which
perfectly encapsulates reacher's
character reacher believes the world is
composed of two types of people people
who stay in one place and people who
wander he believes he's a wanderer that
it's just part of his nature this is
also why he makes sure to correct people
when they call him a vagrant
for the record i'm not a vagrant i'm a
hobo vagrants are people with no jobs
while hobos have historically been
migratory laborers and reacher isn't one
to stray away from work especially if it
means taking down the bad guys this
compulsion to constantly move is so
strong that he leaves behind love
interest roscoe conklin at the end of
the season but if he's such a wanderer
what makes him stay in margrave at the
end of the first episode reacher finds
out that his brother joe just happened
to be murdered in the same town the
night before prompting him to take on a
sort of vigilante justice i'm batman
what he uncovers is an international
criminal organization with crooked cops
spanning local state and federal levels
an organization his brother was looking
to take down but got him killed in the
process teaming up with margrave
detective finlay and officer roscoe
conklin reacher finds out that mayor
teal and beloved multi-millionaire
businessman kleiner have been working
with a criminal organization in
venezuela to produce millions in
counterfeit bills throughout the season
reacher learns that his brother who was
working in the anti-counterfeiting
department of the secret service was
close to uncovering this scheme the only
thing he didn't have was concrete proof
linking those involved with those
counterfeit bills so reacher takes it
upon himself to avenge his brother and
put these bad guys away i guess i'll
find everybody responsible
and kill every last one of them and this
motivation to do what is right stems
from his childhood throughout the season
we get flashbacks of reacher and his
brother as kids reacher beats up a bully
and when he's forced to apologize he
doesn't go through with it even though
it could cost his father his job his
mother sees this strength in him wanting
him to harness it for good you have the
strength of three boys your age
what will you do with that strength
you're going to do what's right perhaps
this was part of his motivation to join
the military not only would it be
following in the footsteps of his father
but it would allow him to do good while
remaining congruent with his wandering
spirit but let's get into the real meat
and potatoes of what's going on in
margrave this is kleiner senior and he
runs a big company that does everything
from manufacturing air conditioners
chemicals and all sorts of random things
he's found a way to counterfeit u.s
hundred dollar bills a bill that should
be nearly impossible to counterfeit
because there's only one entity in the
world that has the ability to print the
special type of paper the bills are made
on that's the us mint rather than create
this paper on their own why not bleach
the ink off a standard one dollar bill
then reprint it as a hundred dollar bill
it's a pretty ingenious scheme but
requires a vast amount of poisonous
chemicals to work and those poisonous
chemicals need to be disposed of so
clarin chemical a subsidiary of kleiner
industries has the brilliant plan of
dumping this waste into a river which
alerts an epa agent fearing their scheme
in jeopardy they have this epa agent
killed and the hitmen responsible for
this is a former partner of fbi h and
picard who is friends with detective
finlay picard who's been helping reach
her in the team throughout the season is
actually one of the bad guys what kind
of cop are you the kind that goes where
the money is so kleiner can't keep
spilling toxic waste into the river or
else they might get caught again so what
do they do buy a [ __ ] ton of cow feed of
course cow feed contains something
called a diatomaceous earth which when
ground up can be used as an effective
cleaning agent for chemical waste this
is why kleiner bought a bunch of cows to
cover up the fact he's been buying so
much cow feed which contains that
special compound but reacher still needs
hard evidence to link kleiner with those
counterfeit bills all he has up to this
point are theories this is where paul
hubble comes in he was blackmailed into
becoming kleiner's financial accountant
responsible for laundering money and
acquiring vast amount of one dollar
bills from payday loan shops and casinos
that could be turned into those
counterfeit hundreds he saw firsthand if
he didn't follow what kleiner said he
and his family could be brutally
murdered while doing the books hubble
finds out that someone has been skimming
money from the top which he pinpoints to
a truck driver responsible for
delivering those counterfeit bills named
pete jobling we never really see pete in
the show but hubble knowing if kleiner
found out pete was stealing from him
would have him killed works with pete
and a federal agent to bring kleiner
down in exchange for immunity and who
happens to be that agent reacher's
brother joe unfortunately for joe and
pete they're killed before they can
expose the whole plan a kill scene which
is the very first thing we see in the
show in the second last episode reacher
uncovers pete's stash of counterfeit
cash the stuff he stole from kleiner
which is the evidence they need to link
kleiner to this criminal activity but
kleiner is dead yes his maniacal son
kleiner jr or kj for short killed his
own father to protect the business see
the old man he had the brains to create
this whole operation but he never had
the guts to do what needed to be done to
protect it not only that it was kj who
killed reacher's brother the final
episode becomes a giant showdown at the
kleiner chemical factory the same
factory where this counterfeit money is
produced kj and mayor teal have hubble's
wife and children along with officer
roscoe as hostages making the assault on
this facility by reacher x-comrad neely
finlay and hubble all the more difficult
what i did like about this final action
scene is how every character was given
an antagonist to fight we have finlay
pitted against the man who betrayed him
roscoe and the mayor a man who killed
her father-like figure and reacher vs kj
it's ironic that the chemical used to
take the ink off the dollar bills
becomes the chemical that lights kj on
fire and kills him with the hostages
saved and reacher victorious in the
epilogue we really get to see how our
characters have changed over the course
of the season the biggest change is
arguably with finley a man who couldn't
get over the death of his wife sharon he
moved from boston because everything
there reminded him of her he's a great
foil to reach her whereas reacher lets
go of people too easily finley can't let
go but at the end of the season finley
has found the courage to move on telling
reacher he's ready to move back to
boston and take care of someone else a
dog he adopts and names jack after
reacher's first name roscoe has also
found the strength to take back the town
her family built even joking with
reacher that she may run for mayor but
has reacher changed it's rare in writing
that we have a protagonist who ends a
season of a show the same person than
when they started this is visually
represented with reacher in episode 1
walking by himself on the side of the
road with episode 8 him doing the same
thing if you have such a static
protagonist you have to make sure that
character becomes the catalyst for
change among the others this is why
finlay thanks reacher for his help
saying that he couldn't have moved on
without him and bonus points if you
caught the cameo of jack reacher author
lee child in the diner at the end i
actually thought it was brian cranston
for a moment we get a flashback of
reacher visiting his mother on her
deathbed she gives him a medal of
bravery that belonged to his grandfather
from world war ii richer will end up
burying this medal where his brother
died a symbol of the bravery it took his
brother to do what is right it takes
bravery to do what's right reacher says
goodbye to roscoe richard just isn't a
man to be held down he is a wanderer
after all she gives him a gift of a
clark bar with her phone number on it a
call back to episode 2 where it was one
of the luxurious vending machine options
at their motel and finally we have to
talk about the pie which also happens to
be the title of the final episode
throughout the entire season it's been a
running egg that whenever reacher orders
the peach pie from the diner he gets
called away before he can eat it finally
he gets to enjoy it stating that he's
had better obviously he hasn't had my
grandmas and as we're left with no more
shirtless reacher until potential season
2 i now turn it over to you was reacher
worth the watch or should amazon give it
the boot let me know your thoughts in
the comments below thanks for watching
everyone be sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram think story yt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you